[Music]
there are still persistent
wage inequalities between men
and women of the order of some 10 7%
on the European average, which hides
extremely strong national disparities
and there are also even more serious
inequalities and loses 2  39% in the long term
of retirement remuneration says that in my
opinion it is absolutely urgent to
seriously reduce
vial and a paying italy by the sea
but from national estoril to bordeaux a
crazy charm
if we do not make strong gestures together
, including when  it is necessary
through legislative instruments to
really really
create equality
other but women not
much happens beyond legislative instruments
I believe
that the whole of society really needs to be mobilized
and that women  themselves are
aware of the enormous potential that
she
not
[Music]